un quartier branché très prisé des
jeunes familles des artères commerciales
en plein essor villeray à la cote est
une toute nouvelle conseillère
d'arrondissement qui ne comprend pas
pourquoi les portes de l'ancien hôpital
chinois demeurent désespérément fermées
c'est inconcevable d'avoir un édifice
qu'eva quand on a 20 ans
il ya eu énormément de confusion dans
les dernières semaines les derniers mois
je dirais les dernières années à savoir
à qui appartient humaine qu'est ce qui
se passe à l'intérieur
aussi il faudrait avoir une information
claire parce que les citoyens et les
citoyennes veulent voir leur quartier
évolué
dans les archives de radio-canada on
trouve des images tournées en 1964 qui
montre la construction de cet hôpital
conçu pour fournir des soins de santé
aux immigrants d'origine chinoise en
un reportage de gilles ces rois raconte
lui une page qui se tourne
peu après 11h ce matin à les tout
derniers pensionnaires quittait les
locaux de la rue saint denis qui ont
servi d'hôpital chinois pendant les 35
dernières années
destination le quartier chinois où les
attend un bâtiment tout neuf et toute
une communauté
c'est l'aboutissement d'un rêve le
retour au tchad à terre ça fait donc dix
huit ans que cet immense édifice est
complètement vide pam qui vivent ici
à l'intérieur derrière les portes
barricadées le temps semble s'être
arrêté
le décor est un peu onirique les plans
de l'édifice
ce mail sur du vieux parti des cintres
semble attendre des vêtements dans des
chambres aux murs abîmés
techniquement c'était difficile dans
lequel la poussière s'accumule depuis
tant d'années appartient à une entité
légale qui s'appelle mon tueur chinese
aspect tôt mais qui relève
administrativement du cija centre sud
on n'a pas trouvé encore preneurs au
condition naturellement souhaité par
rapport à cet immeuble a donc souhaité
par qui par l'hôpital finale montréal
vous comprendrez que l'immeuble une
valeur quand même et pour en disposer un
bon vise à atteindre cette valeur dans
la mesure du possible
donc si cet immeuble évalué à 4 millions
152 milles de l'arrivée des six qui
n'auraient pas trouvé preneur depuis
1999 et en attendant qu'un acheteur
parce une offre cet immeuble vide coûte
entre 50 et 75 mille dollars par année
en frais d'entretien
c'est pourquoi on peut pas visiter comme
je le mentionnais est un processus cette
disposition qui va commencer donc on
souhaite pas pour l'instant effectué le
tournage à l'intérieur puis aussi il
faut se le dire depuis nombreuses années
cet immeuble lloyd inoccupés donc une
question de sécurité aussi processus de
dispositions cela veut dire dans le
jargon administratif qu'on va remettre
l'édifice sur le marché on a bon espoir
que ça va ça va se conclure et qui aura
des beaux des projets intéressants pour
cet immeuble là
un autre édifice vacant ou laissés pour
contre vous intrigue à montréal
écrivez nous et on enquête